[Musique]
des cérémonies de la victoire de 1945
plus modeste pas de parade aérienne pas
de char d'assaut comme d'habitude sauf
un vieux T34 de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
sécurité renforcée partout à Moscou et
autour de la place Rouge suite à
l'incident encore mal expliqué des
drones
les défilés moins grandiose mais un
Vladimir Poutine défiant promettant la
victoire dans ce qu'il appelle pour la
première fois une guerre
une guerre a été lancée contre notre
patrie mais nous avons lutté contre le
terrorisme international dans un
discours d'une dizaine de minutes
seulement il s'en prend à l'Ukraine et
surtout à l'Occident
le peuple craignait une catastrophe
dit-il parce qu'il est devenu
otage d'un coup d'État et du régime
criminel de ces maîtres occidentaux et
de leurs plans cruels et égoïstes
[Musique]
un discours qui résonne encore bien
comme ici aux célébrations de la ville
des caterinbourg parmi la population
russe
apparent nous devons nous défendre à
nouveau contre le néonazisme ressuscité
dans le concert patriotique celle du
chef du groupe paramilitaire Wagner
evgny Prigogine sur le front de barmut
qui accuse les généraux de trahir
Vladimir Poutine
en utilisant des mots grossiers ce sera
lui qui vous détrua où ce sera le peuple
russe
le carnage continue à barkout et dans
l'attente anxieuse de la
contre-offensive ukrainienne le groupe
Wagner n'a toujours pas reçu les
munitions promises
frigogine et furieux les soldats ne
devraient pas mourir à cause de la
stupidité de leur chef
un crime dit-il est en train de se
produire la destruction du peuple russe
la trahison de la patrie est en train de
se produire
Zelenski célèbre la Journée de l'Europe
avec
Ursula vanderleyen la présidente de
l'Union européenne
la sécurité le bien-être et la paix en
Europe à 100% ne peuvent s'instaurer
sans l'Ukraine dit-il en réitérant le
désir d'une adhésion rapide à l'Union
européenne
ces efforts pour y parvenir à
répondirent en pleine guerre sont
remarquables et méritent le respect
alors que la Russie bloque à nouveau la
cheminement des céréales ukrainiennes
dans la mer Noire les Européens
s'efforcent de résoudre le problème des
surplus de produits agricoles Ukrainiens
entrés hors taxes dans les pays membres
qui suscitent de vivre protestation
Jean-Michel Leprince Radio-Canada
Montréal